this map represents the real backbone of
the world's economy this is one of the
most important enclaves on the planet
the strait of hormuz maybe this is the
first time you've heard of this place
nevertheless one out of five oil barrels
brought across the globe departs from
here most of the Gulf's production comes
from this port
as you can see we have three country sir
the United Arab Emirates Amman and the
Islamic Republic of Iran so this place
it could become the battlefield for a
war between America and Iran and believe
me the scenario it actually seems pretty
likely in fact the only reason there is
no war between these two countries now
is because of a last-minute decision
taken by Donald Trump himself by the end
of this video you'll understand what's
going on in this very important region
of the world
[Applause]
[Music]
let's be clear here oil is the lifeblood
of today's economy maybe one day this
will change but nowadays whether we like
it or not we need our dinosaur juice
eventually everything and most of this
crude is carried on tankers this
explains why news like this is quite so
worrisome oil tanker attacks in the
Strait of Hormuz requires an
international response US envoy to Iran
says at the time this video was made six
oil tankers have been attacked some Z
button limpet mines on the ship hulls
live in mines are not very powerful
explosives but they are destructive
enough to make a hole in the hull so the
ship cannot set sail and I might be
wondering well who planted these limpet
mines at this moment on nobody knows for
sure but Donald Trump believes that this
was Iran's doing think about it with the
nuclear sanctions Iran can hardly sell
its oil to anybody this is why the White
House believes since they can't export
crude they decided to close the Strait
of Hormuz
add to this the fact that America hates
Iran in Saudi Arabia hates Iran even
more and of course how the Arabia is
America's best friend especially under
Trump's administration so in other words
Washington doesn't need many excuses to
attacked Iran and Iran is making it even
easier for them in fact in response to
those attacks on the tankers America's
tempted roamed the Iranian coast the
drone was knocked down by a missile sent
by Iran the situation it was extremely
tense but it could get even worse
[Music]
just think about it so far we're talking
about holes in ships and knocks down
drone but no human losses this is where
Trump had to make a decision so the
answer the attack on this drone or not
an air strike on the region would surely
mean the deaths of Iranian people and if
America killed Iranians Iran would want
to kill Americans and in that situation
a dead American soldier would be more
than enough that Donald Trump to start a
war against Iran that's exactly when you
rage a group a consultancy said that
there was a 40 percent chance that the
air strike would start a war and then
against the odds Donald Trump made a
rather sensible last-minute decision
[Applause]
Monday they shot down an unmanned drone
flying in international waters we were
cocked and loaded to retaliate last
night on three different sites when I
asked how many will die under 50 people
sir was the answer from the general 10
minutes before the strike I stopped it
Donald Trump on Twitter is there now the
question is how did we get it there's a
war between America and Iran really that
probable how responsible would Donald
Trump be for it and most important of
all who is attacking these tankers well
today we are going to answer all of
these questions but before we do let's
take a look back at the history
unintended consequences on visual
politic we have a series of videos
devoted to the Iran sanctions if you
want to understand all of this in depth
you should check it out but don't make a
quick summary for everyone who's the new
to this channel for years Iran was
isolated from international trade as
punishment for its nuclear program in
the year 2015 Obama made a deal with
Tehran basically the United States would
lift most of the trade embargo in
exchange for Iran stopping its
manufacturing of nukes
all of a sudden Iran could restart its
oil exports
[Music]
but a year later Trump came to office
one of his first policies was to break
that nuclear deal with Iran according to
him Iran never stopped its nuclear
program despite what anybody said so
from one day to the next America went
back to the embargo the Trumpy didn't
stop here his goal was to make the
entire world stop trading with Iran not
just American companies and this is
where an important question was raised
why would a European company obey what
Washington set well
months later we can say that Trump won
that fight most of the world has stopped
investing in Iran this includes Renault
factories and French oil rigs as you can
imagine this has had terrible
consequences for Iran's economy
[Music]
Iran's latest inflation figure tops 50%
food prices jump 85 percent yep you
heard that right
despite Iran having the world's fourth
largest oil reserves nobody dares to buy
from them so the country is on the edge
of collapse
and on top of all that there are
protests happening against the
government at this point I know what
many of you might be thinking is this
the end of the ayatollah regime in fact
no the opposite is true what is
happening is what we predicted months
ago air at visual politic by the way
this is a good moment to remind you that
we published brand new videos every week
so you should subscribe to this channel
and hit that Bell button when you hit
the bell bus and you actually receive a
notification about when we post new
videos which is nice it means you don't
miss out so you're always up to date
with the best understanding of the
world's politics that's a win-win so as
we said on that video several months ago
in Iranian politics there are three main
factions reformists moderates and
radicals Iran's current president Hassan
rouhani is a moderate this is why he was
willing to reach that nuclear deal with
America
but after the conversations failed his
political capital fell to its lowest
point and who wins in this scenario well
yes that would be the radicals those who
wanted to keep the nuclear program as
any constant never wanted to talk with
the White House so among these radicals
we have a very important group the
Islamic Revolutionary Guard the Islamic
Revolutionary Guard is an elite group
created in order to maintain the values
of the ayatollah revolution they are the
state-of-the-art weapons and world-class
trainings and believe me they have never
been as powerful as they are right now
[Music]
iran's elite defense force finds new
funding sources as tensions rise with
the u.s. as you know iran plays its role
as regional power and it participates in
foreign wars the group that trains the
pro-iranian warriors in countries like
Syria Lebanon and Yemen is this
Revolutionary Guard in recent years the
troops trained by them have increased by
20% for example Hezbollah or the Houthi
rebels are so deadly because of this
training and so how does this
Revolutionary Guard get its funding
while that's with state monopolies
a good share of Iran's economy is in
their hands for example the Iranian
telecom company is owned by them and in
the past few years many other businesses
are falling under their control here's
another example total is a French oil
company with the Trump sanctions they
had to abandon all of their oil rigs so
guess who's taking them now yeah exactly
[Music]
girge drill into Iran's gas potential in
other words Iran's economy is like a
cake now the cake is getting smaller and
smaller but the Revolutionary Guard is
having a bigger and bigger share of us
at this moment we can say that they are
more powerful than the President himself
and this explains news like this brand
new cloutie enriched Iranian limit will
be breached on June 27th in other words
officially Iran is restarting its
nuclear program if Trump thought that
sanctions would push the Ayatollah into
that corner his plan has just backfired
but hold on a minute now because if you
thought the situation couldn't get any
worse well pay attention to this next
chapter
[Music]
got war in Yemen has sort of become the
Arab Vietnam Yemen is the only poor
country in the Arabian Peninsula and
this is the battlefield on which the
Saudis and the Iranians fight their
proxy war initially this was meant to be
a quick war at the end of the day Saudi
Arabia has the third most expensive army
on the planet with top-notch weaponry
American support and tons and tons of
money but as we explained in a previous
video money can buy good weapons but it
cannot buy a good strategy this is why
those who the rebels are causing such a
big headache for the Saudis
and this is a hell of a problem despite
losing the war the Saudis have enough
money to keep fighting without
surrendering theirs honors America and
the UK keep sending weapons Saudi Arabia
will keep bombing and as long as Iran
keeps supporting the Houthis the war in
Yemen won't budge nowadays the violence
in the region is so insane that it's
reached beyond Yemeni borders the toothy
rebels strike Saudi Airport this year in
2019 the Houthi rebels attacked a power
plant and an oil pipe and Saudi
territory but if you thought that was
bad enough here's the news that has
shaken the world's economic backbone oil
tankers attacked the Gulf of Oman at the
time this video was made six oil tankers
have been attacked who orchestrated
these attacks we still don't know
America thinks Iran is behind this and
it seems reasonable that you see rebels
did this these rebels have Iranian
training but they might be acting on
their own behalf
not only that remember that the ones who
are training this group are the Islamic
Revolutionary Guard and those boys they
don't need to arms permission to do
anything
in other words perhaps rouhani doesn't
want to attack oil tankers but even if
it was him he might not be able to
control the Houthi rebels
[Music]
anyway this is all just speculation the
truth is at the time we made this video
nobody has claimed responsibility for
these attacks meanwhile America has sent
1,500 troops to the area this means that
so far Uncle Sam can secure the Strait
of Hormuz but there are still big risks
you see no matter how much military
presence you have there can always be
somebody putting a mine on one of those
tankers doesn't have to be a big attack
nobody dies but this mine is big enough
to blast a hole in the hull and stop the
tanker from sailing what does this all
mean what this means that the companies
that insure those tankers might raise
their premiums and this would have a
direct effect on oil prices worldwide
all of this means that whatever military
presence they send America needs a
diplomatic solution but Iranians they
don't trust Donald Trump after all he is
the one who broke a previously signed
deal so well you can do this job nice of
a look shower
[Music]
our man in Tokyo wherever Shinzo are
they the Japanese Prime Minister anytime
we talk about him on visual politic it's
because we're talking about economics a
crisis or the Olympic Games
the truth is Japan has never been big on
diplomacy until now in June of 2019
Shinzo our they traveled to Tehran to
hold negotiations on behalf of Donald
Trump at the end of the day who wouldn't
trust the Japanese I mean who wouldn't
want to have a beer with that guy I mean
or accept his friendship request on
Facebook it's uncle Shinzo your Japanese
best friends Joe did this plan work well
the answer is a clear and resounding no
[Music]
to Japan bound tank who's reportedly
attacked near Strait of Hormuz that's
what I call not receiving somebody with
open arms
so in conclusion Shinzo our they
returned home sad and Donald Trump
started to do his thing after the attack
on those tankers America sent the drone
Duke spy on the Iranian coast and what
do you think happens well I told you
before the Iranian army they shot it out
of the sky and right at this moment the
tension was higher than ever at this
very moment the Consultancy erasure
group raised the chance of war from 30
to 40 percent and it could get even
worse so what could Donald Trump have
done after his drone had been knocked
down
on the one hand he could have made an
airstrike that this would have probably
ended with the loss of human lives and
see if then Iran had answered with
another airstrike some American soldiers
might have died and dear viewer if an
American died during this conflict Trump
would be almost forced to start a war
and now you might be wondering what does
America want a war here it's well it
would really make no sense whatsoever
first of all as we've seen Iran has a
really big and well-trained army and
we're talking about a country of 18
million people here this is twice as
many people as a in Iraq but not only
that do you really think anybody wants
to have a war at the strait of hormuz in
this case America and the rest of the
world has much more to lose than Iran at
the end of the day Iran cannot export
most of its oil and nobody wants such a
big spike in the market price of oil so
now the question goes to all of you do
you think that despite everything will
end up witnessing a war between America
and Iran do you think the Iran nuclear
sanctions were a good idea how would you
solve this problem well please leave
your answer in the comments section
below also to visit our friends at
reconsider media dock on the podcast
that provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine don't forget we
publish brand new videos every week so
subscribe to this channel and hit that
Bell button so you don't miss out on any
posts and if you like this video give us
a thumbs up and as always I'll see you
next time
if you want to learn more about politics
and world affairs and here's some more
of my lovely boys come check out the
reconsidered podcast where we don't do
the thinking for you find reconsider at
WWE consider mediacom or on Apple or
Google Play or your favorite podcast